hi I'm Ted bellacor with reason TV today
i'll be speaking with roger Nygaard who
is directed television shows such as the
office and the Bernie Mac show Roger is
the director of the celebrated
documentary Trekkies and his new project
the nature of existence promises to
explain the mysteries of the universe in
90 minutes stick around and here Rodgers
take on directing the rise of fan
culture religion and why people get so
angry when their beliefs get challenged
how did you first get into filmmaking
I've just been making films ever since I
can remember it was something I've
always been interested in and I just
kept doing it and luckily I've been able
to get paid to do it you know since I
think 1991 was when I turned pro starred
Julie brown Kevin Nealon and David Spade
before David Spade got on SNL so how did
you move from something like I'm the
monsters level to the to the office the
Bernie Mac state level you just keep
building somebody once told me and I
think it's true it takes five years to
make every big step in the film business
so start out with your little amateur
productions and then you finally maybe
write a script and you make a short film
which leads to somebody seeing it
hopefully and then get giving you an
offer to direct something and really low
budget and maybe that leads to something
and and if it doesn't you just start all
over again try it again if something
like the office which started as a
British version and it's become you know
wildly successful here in the States as
well how much of it it was sort of
ready-made just the style of the humor
for an American audience versus you had
to tweak it for an American audience the
American version of The Office certainly
found its own groove and I think that's
why it became a success you can't just
copy something directly you've got to
reinvent it because every culture is a
little bit different American culture is
a little different from British culture
you know they've got a German office you
know their franchise in the office
other countries and in each one it gets
tweaked a little bit because humor
doesn't always travel for the folks who
may have not seen it yet what's the
logline on Trekkies it's a documentary
about some of the more exceptional fans
of Star Trek and one of the most
exceptional was a young man named
Gabriel I'm going right now to pick up
my new taylormade star trek first
contact uniformed everything that came
out of his mouth was gold Linda
thüringer our clubs captain and gehrig
impersonator bully outdid herself here
except I do have a couple minor quibbles
like the red stripe here in the actual
movie it's gonna be about half this
thickness here at reasoned on TV of
course drew carey's a big deal for us
and he was a big fan of Trekkies can you
tell me about him hooking up with
Gabriel drew Carey saw Trekkies and we
heard about it because we got a phone
call at the production office from Drew
Carey's office saying hey we want to
find that kid Gabriel they ended up
casting Gabriel on the drew carey show
for two episodes to play a Star Trek fan
of some kind it was kind of flattering
that Oh to carry saw the moving liked it
can you talk about the rise of fan
culture I mean certainly it's epitomized
and something like like Trekkies it's
sort of what every television show would
dream of having this this bottom-up
grassroots fan culture what accounts for
that the thing about Star Trek is that
people like to lose themselves in a TV
show and Star Trek was the one science
fiction show or literature that
portrayed a positive future where human
beings are progressing and people are
equal in men and women minorities
everyone has an equal chance science
fiction tends to be the place where we
project our doomsday scenarios and Star
Trek was the opposite of that and it
drew people to that positive portrayal
my new film is called the nature of
existence and the subtitle that I like
is all the mysteries of the universe
explained why are we here is there an
afterlife where is it what is the soul
what is sin does prayer work if so where
was God during the Holocaust and now
I've interviewed hundreds of people all
over the world asking these same
questions I interviewed baba lovers
meher baba from Hindu gurus to jana's
talk to atheists Satanists and Native
Americans rabbi in Israel an archbishop
in Rome Confucianist sand Daoists in
China China is held to be an atheistic
country Confucianism and Taoism are not
truly deistic religions but they are
really superstitious I think every human
nature is super has is has superstition
built into it in some way I was
interviewing a woman in Beijing and I
asked her about religion which religion
did she prefer if any and she said I
don't believe in any sort of religion
and then in the next sentence she was
telling me how she believes that if
there you find a snake on the roof of
your house you should leave it because
it brings good luck if you shoo it away
it'll bring disaster so is so you're
still there's that's still a belief in
some unknown force that you can
influence through your actions why do
people get so angry when their beliefs
are challenged everyone had the same
answer that if you truly believe
whatever it is that you profess to
believe you you have no doubt in your
mind you don't get angry when someone at
questions it you you you discuss it you
have an answer for why if you have
doubts you get angry at someone for
shining a light on your own doubts if
someone is very angry because you're
challenging them it's because they're
trying to keep themselves convinced of
whatever the doctrine is that that they
profess to believe it very rarely say
well well thank you friend for setting
straight oh yeah you can never change
someone's mind I mean rarely if you had
to say a drive cross-country with one of
the folks at your interview dude who
comes to mine oh I've done it I did it
with a preacher and Evangelic ille what
do you call himself a confrontational
evangelist I drove across country with
brother Jed he goes from college to
college preaching fire and brimstone the
type of good old-fashioned you know
you're all going to go to hell if you
don't stop listening to rock and roll
and drinking beer and all the other bad
things and he was he's something else
he's very entertaining he stayed at my
house you know I you know cuz he goes
from place to place he doesn't have
money so I said you know it you're free
to use the guest room open invitation me
so we're gonna you know he might see
this online and he's been there once
come back anytime brother Jed anytime